This represents all the water used in
one year in the Western United States.
For the past 20-plus years, a megadrought,
made worse by manmade global warming
has left the West drier than it’s been
in over a thousand years.
That includes the Colorado River system where
reservoirs have been depleted to record lows.
Which has people talking about ways
to cut back.
“Cities are taking aim at the
backyard swimming pool.”
“Restrictions, such as not washing cars
at home, and no power washing houses.”
“Businesses and residents must cut their
outdoor watering to just one day a week.”
But this is all the residential water use
for 115 million people
across 17 Western states.
All the lawn watering and tooth brushing
and pools and showers
use only 6 percent of all water consumption.
The rest of this tells a totally
different story.
A team of researchers came up with
these water use estimates.
And they found that another 8 percent
goes towards commercial and industrial uses
like offices, hotel fountains, mines,
and power plants.
Together with residential use
that’s 14 percent of all water consumption
in the West.
All of what’s left in here — the other
86 percent is for growing crops.
Irrigated agriculture is the big story.
All the other water users added together...
don't come close to irrigated agriculture.
In the dry western states,
farms can’t count on rain
so crops need irrigation.
So here’s soybeans, nuts, wheat,
fruits & veggies, corn.
But what’s even more surprising is that
the biggest share of this water
goes to crops humans don’t eat.
The biggest water guzzler is alfalfa.
You might not recognize this plant
but if you’ve ever seen a bale of hay that
looks greenish: that’s alfalfa.
Unlike a lot of crops, with enough water
farmers in the West can harvest it up to
12 times a year and sell every last bit.
It's about a 9 to 10 month crop down
in our part of the desert.
And so you're farming it 9 or 10 months
and therefore, you're irrigating it
during that time.
We can group alfalfa’s water with the water
used for other grass hays
and for corn silage.
Together, this accounts for 32% of the West’s
entire water footprint.
And what they have in common is that these
are all crops grown almost exclusively
to feed cows.
That’s more than all the residential and
commercial uses combined.
A third of all the water consumed in the West...
just for feeding cattle.
Americans eat nearly 4 times more beef
than the global average.
Our dairy intake has been increasing
for decades, too.
And we’re not alone.
At least 10% of this cattle feed ends up on
container ships crossing the pacific
to feed cows in Japan, China, and
the Middle East.
Agriculture in the United States is built
to supply a world export market.
So what do we do about this?
It’s clear that letting our lawns die
would make less of an impact than
changing our diets.
But that solution is a hard sell for consumers
even the most informed ones.
In case anybody takes me for like a meat hating
like college professor...
cheeseburgers are my favorite food.
And my cheeseburgers come from
Colorado River water.
So I have thought about it and I think that
before we all stop eating meat
we should explore a couple of
other solutions.
Ben and his co-authors highlight an approach
called “rotational fallowing.”
It enables agencies representing
metropolitan water users
to set a price that they’ll pay farmers
to temporarily stop irrigating
a portion of their fields.
Farmers decide whether it’s worth it in
any given year to take that deal.
And the unused water can then be sent to the
cities...
or left in reservoirs.
Can fallowing hay and alfalfa
in the Colorado River Basin
solve the current 2022 year drought crisis?
The answer is yes.
There’s a long-term agreement like this
in place between the water district that
serves LA and San Diego
and the Palo Verde Irrigation District
in rural California.
The deal allows up to 29% of the total farmland
to be fallowed.
It's been largely well received
in our valley.
I think farmers like it.
Bart Fisher’s farm depends entirely on water
from the Colorado River
so he supports the conservation program.
But he also says it doesn't work for everyone.
Whenever you do fallowing
there are economic losers and economic winners.
And some of our vendors who may sell seed
or fertilizer, they're a loser.
Jobs, communities, and global supply chains
currently rely on western farmers
growing vast amounts of cow food
in the middle of the desert.
But as water supplies continue to shrink,
something has to give:
in how we eat, what we grow, and
where we grow it.
When you look at the water use on the river
the short term savings has to come out
of agriculture.
There's no...
there's no other place to get it.